it's 1992 was the year of the woman
2022 might go down as the year of the
unwoman across the cultural landscape it
suddenly became impossible to say just
what is or who is a woman the battle
over what once was a commonly accepted
definition rages on into the new year as
I'll show you in a moment the issue hit
the culture hard in March when even a
female soon-to-be Supreme Court Justice
couldn't say for sure what a woman is
can you provide a definition for the
word woman I can't
you can't
not in this context
no you don't need a biologist to figure
this out a gyno will do even children
know what a woman is just take a kid to
a toy store the little girl will say I
want the Girl doll the little boy will
say I want the boy doll and a few will
be drawn to this
but that's another story don't distract
me the definition of women or woman
continues to evolve in very odd ways
there was a time when the dictionary
could settle this for us and give us a
definitive answer this year
dictionary.com announced woman as their
word of the year don't cheer just yet
girls dictionary.com must now be edited
by takanji Brown Jackson they write the
dictionary is not the last word on what
defines a woman the word belongs to each
and every woman however they Define
themselves end quote that's not a
definition that's Choose Your Own
Adventure I went to the Cambridge
Dictionary They just added to their
definition a woman to include an adult
who lives and identifies this female
though they may have been said to have a
different sex at Birth
who said what's that the Oxford
dictionary is even more confusing
they've added 18 new gender identity
definitions just this year words like
pangender multisexual brother boy and
sister girl now for a moment I thought
oh wait a guy who had a brother must
have been a brother boy nope Oxford
defines brother boy as a biological girl
who expresses herself as a male are you
confused it seems everybody is
what is a woman can you tell me what a
woman is no I can't
because it's not for me to say I
Womanhood looks different for everybody
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a Womanhood is something that just as
Ethan explained I cannot Define
well this is a problem because language
is how we communicate facts and when
language starts to move in an elastic
fashion so does our perception of
reality for instance I could tell you my
dog is sitting on my lap I call my
leather bag my service dog good boy good
boy you're so sweet now you may say
that's not a dog but tomorrow the Oxford
or Cambridge dictionaries could very
well say dogs are hide bound creatures
that can carry laptops in their bellies
so so long as I put a leash on my
leather bag when we're out there are all
kinds of state laws protecting my pal
and you can't be cruel to my back of my
service dog or leave him in a car now
what we call things has to be precise or
it loses connection with observable
reality
though this year among politicians even
the word mother has been replaced
pregnant people in particular are in
more danger in the United States today
than we were yesterday as a result of
the Supreme Court's decision legislation
has been created to police the bodies of
black birthing people since the
beginning of this nation protects the
freedom of women and pregnant people
is it a birthing person or pregnant
person are they the same thing I do not
know this is from an Ulta beauty podcast
a transgender host interviewed someone
named Dylan Mulvaney to discuss girlhood
Dylan is the one with the red bow
now I know I can find love I know I can
still be a performer I know that I can
have I want to have a family I want to
be a mom one day and I absolutely can
as Dylan pursues motherhood female
activists worry that the federal and
state laws written to protect biological
women from discrimination are being
undermined by these ever broadening
cultural definitions of what it means to
be a woman
female athletes are now competing with
biological men who identify as women my
next guests are sounding the alarm and
say they're taking steps to protect
women's rights hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else